she'll be so excited and surprised Kris
Jenner hints at a proposal between Khloe
Kardashian and Tristan Thompson on
Sunday night's episode of Keeping Up
with the Kardashians the momager
facetimed Khloe's boyfriend about
potential push presents ahead of the 34
year old reality star giving birth to
the couple's daughter true you know Cory
bought me for Christmas a couple years
ago this really beautiful little diamond
ring that's like you can put it on any
finger no until you get that really huge
diamond that's gonna go on her ring
fingers but Tristan laughed off the idea
[Music]
the conversation seemingly happened
before Tristan's cheating scandal okay
love you what push present
that's so cute last month a source told
et that Chloe and Tristan are in a quote
great place
despite weathering the tumultuous
situation that surfaced just days before
Chloe gave birth to true I feel so lucky
then pregnant Chloe was with Kourtney on
vacation in Tokyo or Kim made her
opinion clear she does not like their
fashion sense my sisters look so crazy
like it's actually embarrassing I can't
even eat dinner because I'm so disgusted
with my sister's crazy outfits they
completely don't go with my look you
look like Grandma 100%
so you don't look anything special like
you don't look anything like innovative
and I can do have it in you it's just
better of all before you fizzle out
[Music]